as we've previously reported many Valley
residents resorting to Backyard chickens
to have that constant supply of eggs but
we're also learning the backyard chicken
business could be doing more harm than
good to the birds Victoria Saha takes us
to a chicken Sanctuary near Eastern and
Charleston to explain
the backyard chicken business is growing
but there's another side to it that many
aren't seeing when those chickens aren't
being cared for properly if they're
lucky they end up here at a private
chicken Sanctuary at Camille reyes's
bird sanctuary you can find a pigeons
ducks and chickens I've seen a lot of
negligence more than anything Reyes
dedicates her time to rescuing birds and
rehabilitating them
some are from people who aren't sure
what to do with their chickens anymore
chickens that are dumped in the desert
and lately she's got her hands full
Aaliyah and her sister left eye or Big R
B fans here we're part of five chicks
who were surrendered to us we nursed and
cared for them the best that we could
it's the backyard Chicken Frenzy that's
worrying Reyes the sheer number of
people
that are buying these animals don't
necessarily have the proper knowledge to
care for them as we've told you chicks
are often sold out quickly at stores
during High egg prices and sometimes
one of those chicks can actually be a
rooster
which some areas do not allow
so they get dumped Reyes wants you to
know caring for chickens goes far beyond
building a coop and feeding them taking
in chickens is still large
responsibility they're not starter pets
I personally just discourage anybody to
do so
foreign